hallo mein Name ist Luca meine Damen und
Herren vor einigen Tagen habe ich dieses
Video hier hochgeladen indem ich Netflix
Games gespielt habe und da meinten sehr
viele von euch in den Kommentaren dass
wir too hot to handle weiterspielen
sollen von daher habe ich natürlich
keine Kosten und Mühen gescheut es hat
mich auch einfach nichts gekostet und
mühevoll sind meine Videos jetzt auch
nicht von daher ja keine Ahnung wollen
wir überhaupt hier am Start seid wir
spielen weiter und erwarten die nächsten
zwei Gäste
die Person links sieht entschlossen und
selbstbewusst aus
hallo der Code Herr ist 27 kommt aus den
USA und ist Webdesignerin ja ich bin ja
auch im Web tätig der quota vorne
[Applaus]
und die Rechte hat ein breites Grinsen
im Gesicht und winkt der Gruppe zu
schade ist es nämlich
geworden Museums katakakatore Loren noch
zwei schöne Frauen der sieht einfach
halt wirklich null aus wie ich ne ist
hier in dieser Show jeder einfach absurd
attraktiv
was ist das für eine weather Typ und
warum habe ich eine Krebs Unterhose an
ich habe lust auf einen heißen Sommer da
weiß man ja gar nicht für wen man sich
entscheiden soll oder gut dass ich mich
angemeldet habe ich habe natürlich lust
auf einen heißen Sommer
auch stark dass man immer Punkte
bekommen wenn man eine Antwort
auswählt was geht ab Party People ich
bin Jana sie wird Dir Marisa in
beiläufiges Lächeln zu aber sie hat ein
Auge auf Liam okay dann habe ich hier
kein Interesse daran und ich bin der
Kota Dakota zeigt auf dein Getränk und
ich nehme was du hast bitte aber erst
würde ich zu gerne deinen Namen erfahren
oh
die nimmt schon mal das was ich möchte
das auch immer guter Flirt Ansatz wenn
man irgendwo unterwegs ist einfach das
nehmen was die anderen Personen egal wie
ihr Mädel seid oder ein Junge wenn die
andere Person bestellt einfach genau
damit zeigst du deiner Person ey guck
mal ich mag das gleiche
der
vielleicht doch nicht so schlau du
reichst dir ein Glas Champagner ich bin
Luca passt zu dir was passt zu dir
positiv oder negativ Prost Luca sie
nimmt einen Schluck und schließt dann
zufrieden ihre Augen hmmh was für ein
perfekter Tag du äußerst
was macht der Luca für komische Sachen
steht er mit seiner krebsbadehose am
Strand und beäugt neuankömmige ja da
scheint an Liam interessiert zu sein
aber Dakota kann nicht aufhören mich
anzustarten ich sollte sie besser
kennenlernen ja oder wir nehmen nicht
das erst beste und warten vielleicht mal
ab dieses Gesicht zeigt dass der Typ
glaube ich eher nicht abwarten will also
was verschlägt dich auf diese Paradies
Sprachen lernen Babbel paradiesische
Insel Dakota ach weißt du ich nehme eine
Auszeit von meiner Arbeit als
Webdesignerin und meine niederen nie
nie drin Instinkte nee ich will doch
nicht diese Dakota wenn du verstehst was
ich meine nee verstehe ich eben nicht
ihre niederen Instinkte besser kennen er
würde mir zuhören dass ich sofort ich
verstehe kann ich dabei helfen ich weiß
genau
ich weiß genau was du meinst ich glaube
das tue ich
ich habe die Stelle keine Gegenfrage gut
das habe ich mir schon gedacht sie
zwinkert dir verspielt zu
ach nee verspielt
dieses Video schon wieder du wolltest
etwas anderes sagen aber dann merkst du
wie dich jemand ansieht als du dich
umdrehst bemerkst du dass Liam ja da
überhaupt keine Aufmerksamkeit schenkt
sein Blick ist nach wie vor in deine
Richtung
ist glaube ich schwul interessant aber
dann vergisst du Liam Marisa und Dakota
denn eine weitere
um Alex
in der jetzt auch noch auf mich steht ne
doch nicht nur du hast den neu
Ankömmling im Auge jeder Stadt mit
offenem Mund der wie mit offenem Mund
schöner als alles so oder was
meine Güte ich glaube ich bin gerade
sehr durstig geworden oh mein Gott
es ist so peinlich der neueste
Teilnehmer stößt mit einem
selbstbewussten breiten Grinsen auf die
Gruppe
ja okay so glaube ich jetzt nicht Hallo
zusammen ich bin Alex lass mich raten du
bist Martin weil verdammt noch mal junge
bei deinen Augen kauf ich direkt die
gesamte Kollektion
ey bin ich hier gelandet und geraten was
mein Beruf angeht aber eigentlich
identifiziere ich mich als nicht binär
ja ich identifiziere mich eigentlich als
Flugzeug ich benutze das Pronomen Xia
ach das war kein Rechtschreibfehler im
ersten Part wo ich das gespielt habe
dachte ich dass wir ein
Rechtschreibfehler gewesen sorry falls
ich damit irgendwie auf die Schuhe
treten möchte ihr kennt mich ich will
hier niemanden verletzen mir ist es
scheißegal als was ihr euch seht ihr
könnt euch auch denken ihr seid die
Sonne Hauptsache seid korrekt und zu
eure Mitmenschen nicht gegenüber aber
was genau bedeutet das
hier
ich kenne nur Xylophon cool danke für
die Info die ja da glaube ich Ihr
Interesse daran verloren wir kommen
Paradies Alex alle widmen sich nach und
nach wieder ihren Gesprächen aber du
kannst deinen Blick nicht von Alex
abwenden
ich stehe nicht auf Alex euer Blick
trifft sich kurz Alex stellt sicher dass
du es bemerkt hast und schaut dann
schüchtern Weg der hatte was am Auge
kleben der Luca etwas anziehen das an
sich und ein Interesse ist geweckten
scheiße ist hier geweckt also wenn
überhaupt würde ich dir die Dakota
nehmen von den allen aber wir sind immer
tot wir dürfen eh nichts miteinander
haben hey Alex hey hör doch bitte nein
Luca ich bin Luca er
ich habe auch eine
Fluggesellschaft die heißt Luca er
Alex schenkt dir ein freundliches
Lächeln nee der soll mir gar nichts
schenken
also ihr könnt mir den Helikopter
schenken darauf hätte ich schon Bock ihr
tauscht ein Lächeln aus doch dann ziehen
zwei Männer die auf die Gruppe zugehen
plötzlich alle Aufmerksamkeit auf können
nicht noch ein paar mittels kommen der
linke winkt direkt und versucht allen
ein High Five zu geben boah so ich ne
ich komme dann moin hallo
alles klar okay wenn man da Haie
schreien würde am Strand wird vielleicht
auch nicht so Sinn
[Musik]
verstanden
oh mein Gott
ist 28 kommt aus Frankreich und ist
Personal Trainer
es war so klar dass der Bus sagt nur die
Franzosen und Italiener sind so sprachen
verliebt dass sie das immer wieder
einlaufen lassen ihren englischen Slang
oder in diesem Fall Deutsch sowas wie
bonjour oder bonjo Bella Grazia danke
schön bitte schön einfach diese
Aussprache was ist das wenn ich
Deutscher in ein als Deutschland sondern
amerikanische reality TV nein
[Musik]
nein
hat dieser Justin wirklich gerade den
Witz gebracht just in time kann ich dem
einfach eine rein schlagen der gibt mit
seinem Bizeps an und bringt alle zum lau
mein Gott das ist ja eins zu eins ich
dieser Justin der Typ neben ihm
schüttelt genervt den Kopf oh mein Gott
ey ich bin Justin
das ist eins zu eins ich theo ist am
Start aber Bananenbrot mitgebracht oder
wie
sind ein paar Musik heiß oder wie du
lässt ihn von Kopf bis Fuß auf dich
wirken hallo Mister groß dunkel und
schön du siehst aus wie Schwierigkeiten
ein Traum wird wahr oder mehr Konkurrenz
ich sagen sieht aus wie mein Fuß ich
muss das ehrlich gesagt gerade erstmal
kurz wirken lassen von daher würde ich
an der Stelle die heutige Episode 2 hot
to handle mit Luca auch beenden wenn es
euch gefallen hat dann lasst gern einen
Daumen hoch unter dem Video hier da
abonniert meinen Kanal und klickt auf
die Glocke um weitere Videos nichts
verpassen wie soll ich mich im nächsten
Part Verhalten oder soll überhaupt ein
nächster Part kommen in die Kommentare
ich habe Angst dass ich mehr
Gemeinsamkeiten mit einem Teilnehmer
dort habe als mit mir selber